quiero echarle un vistazo a nuestros dos
circuitos con amplificadores
operacionales y hacer una observación
interesante acerca de cómo éstos se
comportan cuando están actuando de
manera adecuada cuando están bien
conectados hay algo que hacen estos
elementos que es muy útil y nos
facilitan la vida dejemos que la
ganancia de nuestro amplificador
operacional sea de 10 a la 3 no no mejor
10 a las 6 una ganancia muy alta un
millón y dejaremos que el voltaje de
salida aquí sea de digamos
6 puntos
y recuerda que lo que no se muestra en
este circuito son las fuentes de
alimentación saliendo de estos 2 ams más
menos digamos que son de más menos 12
volts esas fuentes de alimentación son
implícitas no se muestran en el diagrama
pero sabemos que están ahí bien si el
voltaje de salida es de 6 volts y ya es
10 a las 6 entonces de cuánto es el
voltaje de entrada el voltaje de entrada
es la diferencia entre estos dos
voltajes de aquí llamemos a esto de la
manera convencional este será de más y
llamaremos a este b - y sabemos que el
voltaje de entrada sabemos que el
voltaje de entrada es igual a de más o
menos
y ahora la pregunta es cuánto es el
voltaje de entrada en términos del
voltaje de salida el voltaje de entrada
es igual al voltaje de salida
/ / a
si sustituimos los valores que fijamos
tenemos 6 volts divididos entre 10 a las
6 micro volts hay 6 micro volts entre
este punto y este bien con 6 volts aquí
hay 6 micro volts por aquí
bien este voltaje es muy pequeño para
que esté
amp tenga un voltaje de salida que
permanezca entre más menos 12 volts este
voltaje de aquí tiene que ser muy
pequeño debe de estar en el orden de
micro volts y ya que soy una ingeniera
práctica sólo diré que esto es
aproximadamente 0 volts y si digo que
éste es 0 es casi lo mismo que decir que
de más es aproximadamente igual a b -
esa es una pequeña observación que
haremos justo ahí
en este circuito cuando está trabajando
apropiadamente estos dos voltajes son
prácticamente iguales tomemos esta idea
de que demás es prácticamente igual a b
- y apliquemos la a este circuito de
aquí
ahora esta es nuestra configuración de
amplificador inversor este es de más y
este es de menos en este circuito
hagamos el mismo análisis que hicimos
antes si este es el voltaje de salida y
si el voltaje de salida es de 6 volts
eso significa que de más menos de menos
dividido entre 10 a la 6 es igual a 6
micro volts y esto significa que esto es
micro volts en esta dirección
cuando hicimos esto aquí ya que los
signos de las entradas están cambiados
esto era
micro volts de esta manera nuevamente
debido a la ganancia enorme de este
amplificador esto siempre será un número
muy pequeño y por lo tanto por qué no
hacerlo cero
si considero este como 0 lo que
significa es que iré aquí y lo cambiaré
a 0
botox
hagamos un poco más de observaciones de
acuerdo justo ahora aquí dice que de más
es igual a cero porque está conectada a
tierra así que cuánto vale de menos
bueno pues ve - también es 0 de menos es
0 este punto de allí está a 0 puntos
bien eso es bastante útil entonces ese
punto está a 0 volts ahora está
conectado a tierra no está conectado a
tierra pero es 0 volts debido a lo que
esté anp está haciendo por nosotros este
amplificador lo permite haciendo que
este paso de retroalimentación que este
nodo esté siempre junto a este nodo y
eso significa que siempre es 0 hay una
palabra bastante apropiada que
utilizamos para esto y la palabra es
virtual
y qué significa la palabra virtual
virtual significa algo que no está
ay
pero
parece
pero parece que sí lo está en este caso
este nodo no está conectado a la tierra
pero parece como si lo estuviera así que
nos referimos a esto como
ra
actual
esas dos ideas dicen lo mismo de más es
igual a menos es siempre la situación en
la entrada de un amplificador
operacional cuando está funcionando
adecuadamente y en el caso particular de
esta configuración de op
amp donde la terminal positiva está
conectada a tierra decimos que la otra
terminal d - está en una tierra virtual
o es una tierra virtual en el siguiente
vídeo regresaré y haré esa configuración
del amplificador inversor haré el
análisis nuevamente con este concepto de
tierra virtual y será muy sencillo si lo
comparamos con hacer todo el desarrollo
algebraico